now firstly some of you did not know
what a data dictionary
was okay so i'm looking for four main
headings in a data dictionary okay
you should have had a field data type
size
description some of you included the
example that's fine but it wasn't the
most important part
now um what here we hold on let's see uh
are we still that's b okay you're still
you guys doing the table that's right
we'll get there
now let's talk about the fields firstly
now i admit this is probably my fault so
i didn't deduct marks for this but a
note for you guys later if you want to
drop this down right
the names of the fields they really
ought to be single words right no spaces
okay so things like say card id
card id um something like this
i would write it like this card id okay
um not as i saw for some of you
okay that is not a field well i mean
okay like i said i didn't i wasn't big
on this before
but um the fields shouldn't have spaces
in them okay so a card id
is fine right
um now i was very careful you couldn't
just pick any
um fields you liked right so the typical
ones they're going to come up in a
second card id
name um balance was a really important
one
some of you put things like say a bank
account number right now
i'll get to this when i have a look at
part
part d and we'll talk about the social
and ethical issues
but it's very very unlikely that the
department of education department of
transport right
that they'll put someone's bank account
number on the card that they're actually
carrying around with them
why is that such a crazy idea
what are they what what risk are they
opening themselves up to you by putting
a bank account number on a card
doesn't it say that it's just about the
system
yeah yeah well it's about think about
like
what you're going to know about them
it's it's really about what's on the
card right
i didn't knock marks for it it became it
again it became an issue later on
but it's a weird thing to put in there
okay um some of you forgot
that you have like you know the week's
journeys that you know about them
because
that way you can give them a um you can
give them a
discount right so somebody just forgot
about that but that's a crucial piece of
information
right so uh that's the field
now data type uh this was mostly well
done there are too many things to get
roll
um some of you though you forgot about
the boolean data if you forgot it
existed
right so that's just a yes no zero one
true false kind of feel very very useful
okay um size again no problems
descriptions so long as you've got the
right fields most people will find
on there okay but let's move on to
part b